Cuddling...it’s the universal way of showing
affection, whether it’s mother & child,
star-crossed lovers, or me and my cat Mr.
Mittens curled up on the couch binge watching
Orange Is the New Black.
Hey cuddle bugs, it’s Natalia for DNews!
I don’t know about you, but I’m the type
of person that thoroughly enjoys cuddling!
In fact, I fancy myself as a competitive spooner.
I can easily switch from little to big spoon
while deftly maintaining my soothing effectiveness.
But did you know cuddling has some pretty
amazing health and relationship benefits?
Physical contact, like cuddling, helps build
bonds and form intimacy between participants.
Intimacy, in turn, builds trust which makes
for stronger relationships.
The reason being is that touch increases the
release of oxytocin, a neuropeptide, which
promotes trust, devotion, and bonding.
In fact, oxytocin is often called the “cuddle
hormone”.
A recent study in England was able to find
the area of the brain that reacts to touch.
Researchers discovered that a light touch
on the arm made the orbital frontal cortex
light up, like it does when one experiences
other rewarding stimuli.
These findings suggest that cuddling has the
biological ability to build connections!
A study published in the Journal of Social
and Personal Relationship focused on a sample
of 397 couples in committed relationships
and found that the initiation of physical
contact, regardless if it led to nookie or
not, positively affected the relationship.
A University of Toronto study has also shown
that post coital cuddles can be the key to
relationship happiness and success.
Participants filled out a survey about their
foreplay, love making duration, and post coital
cuddling practices and results found that
what came AFTER the main event seemed to have
the greatest effect in terms of relationship
satisfaction.
However, cuddling is not for everyone.
Some folks aren’t so keen on snuggling up.
But, take heed, anti-embracers!
Science says physical touch is actually good
for your health...
In fact, science even says hugs can stave
off illness while keeping you feeling connected
to others.
Studies have shown that hugs led to decreased
levels of the stress hormone cortisol.
Sure, some can argue that more hugs mean more
potential contact with pathogens, but because
hugs help decrease stress that can be more
harmful to your health in the long-run, they’re
worth the risk!
And since cuddling is like one big hug with
your whole body, it’s a perfect way to relieve
stress.
So science says, go ahead, get your cuddle
on!
Some people don’t like touch at all.
Autistic animal behaviorist Temple Grandin
was adverse to touch as child.
She suffered from tantrums and didn’t speak.
As she grew older she realized the importance
of touch and hugging as a way to reduce anxiety
and alleviate her symptoms.
She sought to develop a device that could
help autistic individuals, children with ADHD,
and animals learn to tolerate touch with the
goal of reducing anxiety.
The device she developed was called “The
Squeeze Machine” and was marketed as a ‘hug
machine’ that provides deep tissue touch.
The device has proved effective in children,
adults, and animals.
Cuddling is wonderful.
And it’s one of the best ways to show someone
you love that you care...and it sometimes
it leads to a kiss.
But don’t forget, every kiss begins with
Kay.
Touch is a huge part of how we experience
the world, we are touching things constantly
every single day, but do you get the science
behind touch?
Julia does in her video here.
Thanks for watching and be sure to subscribe
for DNews every day of the week!
Huh, all this talk about cuddling makes me
want a hug
Do you guys like to cuddle?
Or would you prefer a squeeze machine?
Tell us down in the comments below and don’t
forget to hit subscribe for more DNews episodes
every day of the week.